bro this is amazing
I am so stoked are you stoked tell me
your stuff yeah I'm step over coffee
it's pretty two blocks away from us yes
us coffee shop chick you
delicious-looking pastries hi
did you order with the app or would you
prefer a verbal transaction that's gonna
be a verbal order I'll take a Columbian
perfect
wait are you local yeah we will have
done wat cool I'll give you guys some
seats with your coffee we're running a
guerilla gardening project take back the
streets you know so disruptive I love it
I'm actually a local taste maker I post
up and support the support move okay
thank you Quinn and all actually I got
this gear he'll have an El Salvador why
that's a good choice bro trust me you're
not ready for a Kalam definitely stick
with me all South training wish he's
right you're not I'm the one who
introduced you to pour over Quinn but
now the student has become the teacher
I copy knowledge is way past trade and
the teachers gain tenure while the
student is like barely skating behind
he's seen a tutor I don't need a to
thinking of switching to past better
training wheels are completely off right
now I'm speeding on a Ducati going 120
miles per day to a coffee bean field at
dog sure but meanwhile I'm popping a
sick wheelie on my cañedo bike and
fashion in the skull of a Neo Tokyo
Street thug with a bag of Fairtrade you
don't have the upper body strap
screaming do you think this is a game do
you think this is a game it's not a game
zhaibar you see that girl over there way
which one Brad necessary looks like she
hasn't slept in weeks
um yeah I'm like super turned on by her
it's really doing it for me I'm gonna be
honest on a subconscious level it might
be one front right now oh my god
she just pulled out a moleskin journal
bro I think I have excuse me
cancel the else Alvarez ill and I'll
have a Kenyan did you just cross the
Atlantic are you scared
you are a wild man I'm actually going to
need a manager's approval to prove that
you're clearly not ready for
pay-per-view we'll both have Kenyan good
we're approved mmm a nice technique yeah
yeah that's uh that's a good technique
also for anyone interested I've got a
lot of knowledge of the process that's
uh what is this you're giving a lunch
teasing the grinds right now tickling
the frijoles as some people would say it
makes also worth noting that water is
195 to 205 degrees Fahrenheit per chair
for coarse ground 60 grams of coffee for
every 1 liter of water yeah that that's
or you could also do a 120 grams of
coffee for every to 2 liters of water so
it's just math just simple math okay we
cut to this yesterday for the first time
three people fainted
fair trade fair warning I'm really gonna
enjoy this flavor profile I'm glad I'm
blessed with such a refined palate okay
can I ask you a question just let me you
think this is a game Quinn I can't hear
you I guess you should step closer to me
I'm I'm not gonna move closer just stop
whispering do you think this is okay I
can't hear you then I guess move move
closer okay fine I'm gonna I'm gonna
step over here Quinn but it's not again
oh sorry I guess you won't be able to
enjoy that Kenyon looks like you spilled
your coffee apologies about my friend
he's just like a total nightmare in the
mornings I'll be honest with you I never
wanted to see that Kenyan touch his lips
thank you here take these alfalfa seeds
we do dawn for just Tuesdays and
Thursdays it's very freeform that is so
rad a 100 percent be there hey guys
please subscribe to the GQ channel where
you can listen to me Garrett the lobster
who actually knows about 400 copy posted
tips and tricks